How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his new News Now program in
Spanish after several months of
hospitalization, Metro 6 officer
Mickalonis is back in Las Vegas '
surrounded by his loved ones His family
confirmed this good news on their
social media mixers  he
was shot and seriously injured
during a smarter plate protest
in june he was hospitalized and
transferred to denver for special care
since august however his
relatives said his condition is still
serious and without recovery it is quite a
challenge the little ones  joins leds
to provide free roundtrip rides
to vaccination sites that
's how i hear it you must be a
north las vegas resident and have an appointment for
this service to receive the code you
must call 70 26 23 21 36
and this  afternoon the largest
convention space in downtown las vegas
officially opens the expo at the
world market center was in
2 year construction includes close to
200,000 square feet of exhibition
areas for meetings and of course an
exclusive food place and now
we turn to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures in the 80s
by today Friday it is expected that these will
increase by the weekend near  From
the 90s, however, the winds return
to the valley for next week. I am
Cristian Cáceres with Suffer
from News Now in Spanish. Good day.